Manny Pacquiao Floyd Mayweather could
punch over 50 times and 10 seconds based
on slight training footage do you think
you could punch more than that I'm not
sure I could try I think she can I think
I would do really bad how many punches
you think you throw in 10 seconds 10 hey
that's that no I said oh well that's
like for us like well I think a thousand
might be too high of a number but I am
from Grand Rapids like Floyd so we'll
see we'll see hometown advantage maybe
and maybe three
41 i cotton 41 I counted 43 at 48 46 45
551 354 kind of surprised a little
winded when I'm kind of surprised so how
do you think you did champion um I think
I you probably did good that I thought I
heard the little girl did a 41 uh you
know what I mean you always like to make
sure that you're kind of liking the same
the same arrange as your opponents as a
little girl you know I mean not I me I
mean a fight as a fight as a fight as a
fight I was getting paid like as much as
uh what's-his-name Pacquiao and Floyd
Mayweather yeah I probably looked a lot
better
were you guys surprised it's more of a
nice friend yeah oh yeah that's a thanks
fellas I support from your friends who
do you guys got in the fight you know me
whether an Apache are annoyed me with it
boy
Boyd mayweather-pacquiao well I'm gonna
go for Floyd but I'm gonna go ahead and
say Manny pack you up for the win
so I'm gonna say Mayweather gonna have
to go in Merriweather Mayweather you
only nine less than the the heavyweight
champ of the world how do you feel about
that